do you ever hear the story about when i
ran into a sliding glass door
i mean i remember the one about me and
kayla running into sliding glass doors
okay when i was about 10 years old
i was uh
in the backyard mowing the lawn
and um
i wasn't allowed to come in until
everyone else was eating dinner but i
had put off mowing the lawn all day and
my dad was like
hey man
i told you
you had to mow the lawn today sun's
going down and i was like but there's
dinner and he was like well then mow the
lawn before dinner
so i could see them they were in the
living room i could see them sliding
glass door our our living room i mean
not living our dining room they were
eating dinner our dining room was
it was a oddly set up house but i could
see them through the back door
sliding glass door
i'm mowing the lawn
and um
a bee
doesn't sting me dude
and look i'm going to come out and admit
this even though none of my family
listens to this podcast
was it a bee i don't know it went in z
and it came near me here
and
and i'm for those who listen i'm
pointing on my neck and
it's
and i [__]
[Music]
freaked out man i let go of the
lawnmower and i just started running
inside
and i remember
seeing my brother jonathan
just with a fork just kind of looking
out the window
and as i'm getting closer he's just
still looking like
and i ran
a head full of panic straight into that
sliding glass door bounced off boom
got up open that door shut it lawnmower
was [__]
but
so
i've always convinced myself this is
interesting by the way i'll get to a
point
i'd always convince myself that i was
just scared of bees
and then i had you guys
and
i was like oh i can't react like that
anymore there were so many things that i
thought i was scared of
i just told myself i was but then when i
had you guys i was like oh i can't
react like this anymore
this is not i'm the person in charge i'm
not being taken care of i am the
caretaker so i cannot so it was so weird
how your my brain was like yeah you're
not allowed to be scared of that [__]
anymore and i just
even though i could feel it inside i
didn't do the outward reaction you guys
cured me
[Music]